Analysis of Mitochondrial DNA reveals that
a resourceful 5,300 year old Iceman wore a
sheepskin loincloth, cow leather shoelaces,
goat hide leggings, sheep and goat mixed coat,
a brown bear hat.
Meanwhile, researchers at Stanford developed
a new fabric that, unlike cotton, allows infrared
radiation to pass through it.
So you’ll feel four degrees cooler if you’re
wearing plastic clothes.
Vsauce!
Kevin here - this is Mind Blow.
DuoSkin makes your arm an interface.
Developed by the MIT Media Lab, a cheap, skin-safe
gold leaf material is attached in various
designs to the skin.
The three interfaces include wireless communication,
touch-sensing input and displaying output.
The metallic temporary tattoos can control
mobile devices like a trackpad, and also data
like movie tickets could be embedded in the
material.
They believe on-skin electronics will become
less taboo over time and develop into user-friendly
body decoration.
In science fiction becomes reality news, an
astronaut sequenced DNA in space.
While aboard the International Space Station,
a Biomolecule Sequencer was used to identify
the DNA sequence of a mouse, virus and bacteria
while identical samples were sequenced at
the same time on Earth to control for differences
in results.
Current practical applications include being
able to test the fungi growing on the ISS
without having to send it back to Earth and
future amazing applications include detecting
life on Mars.
Virtual reality, brain-control and a robotic
exoskeleton combine to retrain people to walk.
The system allows patients with spinal-cord
injuries to regain voluntary leg muscle movement
and feel touch and pain in their paralyzed
limbs.
After 12 months of training, which involved
patients imagining walking through a virtual
scene, the EEG picked up signals for the lower
limbs that had been previously lost.
The patients wore sleeves with haptic feedback
to react to each step, and even varied so
walking on sand would feel different than
walking on grass.
Eventually they could walk in the
real world with robotic training devices
and the research is ongoing.
The oldest fossils ever found are 3.7 billion
years old.
Australian geologists discovered a newly exposed
outcrop of sedimentary rocks and minerals
in Greenland that was previously covered in
snow.
They found evidence of fossilized microbial
mats called stromatolites
which are shallow water microorganism communities.
Due to the complexity of stromatolites they
believe life may have started much earlier
than when they appear in the fossil record
and this discovery increases interest in life
on other planets.
There’s now a drone that drops ignition
spheres to start fires.
The Unmanned Aerial System for Firefighting
was created to safely perform prescribed fires
that are used to combat the spread of wildfires
and benefit ecosystems by fighting off invasive species.
Traditionally, helicopter-based ignition has
been used but its expensive and dangerous
- so this new system represents a major upgrade
in fire.
EPFL built a robotic foosball table.
A camera under the table tracks the ball and
linear and rotational motors control the players.
The robot can already beat humans.
The robot knows where the human player is
positioned and can react accordingly.
And now they’re working on having a robot
play against another robot.
3D Printing now enters 4D.
Engineers are printing shape-changing polymers
that remember their original shape when heated
to specific temperatures.
They believe what they call 4-D printing could
be used for biomedical devices like medicine
that’s released when the patient has a fever
or used for solar cells that move in relation
to temperature to optimize performance.
Really i just think this little soft polymer
claw thing looks cool.
So yeah.
Finally, DFKI in Germany unveiled a project
to search for extraterrestrial life in the
deep oceans of Jupiter’s moon Europa.
*SFX*
I’m gonna leave you with a virtual reality
robot arm,
And as always, thanks for watching.
*SFX*
You are about to take a journey out of this
world,
Into the world of the future.
Forget the world around you.
Forget the people around you.
You are entering Futurama.
It’s hard to believe there actually is an
oven that can cook a roast in minutes by electronics.
Then bake you potatoes in less time than it takes
to carve the roast.
A refrigerated cart ready for wheeling into
a game room or out on to the patio.
Perfect for keeping foods and drinks cool
for informal entertaining.
Yes, that’s a wonderful idea.
And I’ll bet this washer will get anything clean,
Even my most delicate things.
Did you have fun?
I sure did.
Everything I saw was out of this world.
*SFX*
There’s a brand new episode of LÜT over
on DONG.
So click here to check that out.
And while we’re working on the second box,
Curiosity Box number one is almost sold out.
So if you’re the type of person that’s
gotta catch ‘em all make make sure you subscribe
to The Curiosity Box today.
Just go to CuriosityBox.com.
There’s also a link at the top of this video’s
description.
So you can click that.
Yeah.